ça va vous être remis des révélations du
dernier épisode moi pas c'est parti pour
le septième épisode là c'est directement
la suite eu je pense qu'on va revenir
dans le présent du coup après cette
ellipse yes yes yes yes
du coup il m'a pas bouffer salah
yvetot petits as you go to lose y attend
aussi beaucoup qu omar again arabo son
hymne à kouba stage au brésil contrôler
son mât non s'enflammer
[Musique]
et mon petit
voilà ce que moi tricot comme réveiller
mais ce sens va d'ici il a réussi à
lutter contre les ondes en cause
je suis pas avais je pas réveiller sois
patient désolé voilà il est tout triste
tu as envie je reviens d'un voyage
tu as steaks hachés moi mais au soleil
pour que ça me réveille sais pas quoi
cette crise mondiale avec toi tu rentres
rester tricot
sahil a plus d'idées sait plus quoi
faire tricot ça le met trop mal
attendue et annoncée
ces petits détails trop bien fait que
par exemple il met sa patte dans l'autre
avant de me mettre dedans sans vérifier
qu'elle est pas trop froid de votre
choix
tout ça parce que mon chèque bike
on se réveille rouge en tricot commence
à mon grand je te monde le sud direct ah
bah oui tu es content aïe aïe attention
au [ __ ] quel bon les huit vidéos
linverse du début de du septième épisode
vous avez vu la ja tricot hinault câline
il est tout content on est bien là on
est là bas il semble j'espère qu'on aura
plus on a si tu redeviens méchant ça va
le faire pour moi attend peut-être silao
attend ses six enfants
lacie se met debout contre ça moi je
peux aller là-haut voilà tu te met
debout vas-y tu as vu à rennes ya trois
ans wade à cork et ses choix calculette
sact a mis un petit peu de temps
j'aurais pu me faire embaucher par les
trucs du dessus donc je passe de l'autre
côté puis va y avoir un petit levier la
folle napoles pas vers un petit flirt
ouvrir on finirait pas seul à seul est
pressante aux abricots tu sais bien
aucun petit technique
easy lemon squeeze échelle voilà rien
question je t'avais dit loi faut qu'on
s'écoute faut qu'on communique
elle est jours avant son
oooh c'est beau ça ça fait une petite
mine on est dans une petite mine
clairement vous allez voir ce qui s'y
cache un vrai tu passes patricot
j'aimerais mettre un petit un petit
baril pour te donner à manger
même si on dirait que les ondes qui
feront du vilain est ton plus précoce en
8e fait pas pousser cette porte
tu l'as plus vite fait à mais non c'est
peut-être moi je dois faire un tour en
fait d'un magnum s'il n'y a pas d'accès
ici vers la droite tête s'y met sa tête
je peux accéder à un truc en hauteur à
caylar tu peux rentrer et à peut-être là
dedans ou pas dis-moi tricot avait passé
un truc il en train de ramper très bien
ça il faut que je m'adapte est un powell
c'est ça mon gars pour atteindre la
barre ou la pas directement à t'en vas y
avait rien ne bouge pas moche moche quoi
yes mes recettes l'écho tâche pensais
vraiment que je pensais vraiment pas
qu'ils pouvaient venir comme ça je suis
jamais très très bien a cédé cailloux ça
mais si on est de l'autre côté des
portes on va pouvoir les ouvrir et puis
on va continuer là-bas je pense que je
tourne mon gant voilà allez va venir et
va comprendre tout seul comme un grand
ici qu'est ce qu'on a ou la lumière au
bout donc tu viens pas tu peux ramper en
voilà accroupi le pauvre souhaite
tellement oppressant
elle ramène toi je vais t'ouvrir mon
gars allait bien j'étais ouvert mon vite
s est coincé mais n'ont pas pensé
si je t'ai fait mettre sa tête l'as
cannes pour une raison dans le froid a
fait un regard du passé
oh merde encore un éboulement
[ __ ] c'est normal décidément on
n'arrête pas d'être sais pas je répète
qu'on le voit vieux du coup parce que
quand il raconte l'histoire et une voix
d'homme et ou non je pense à doit être
dix ans plus tard minimum
j'aimerais bien voir sa tête juste à
comberlin hockey à hawaï tricoter mal
[ __ ] bon écoute je peux que passer
vers là pour sortir est-ce que je vais
pouvoir t'aider à sortir de là un thé
complètement ensevelis montgrand des
congés doit remonter dessus pour accéder
à la sortie [ __ ] merde il faut que
trois moyens de l'aider là comment je
peux faire
il est complètement sous les décombres
un hoquet est un faux je me dépêche
je les pêches parce que ça doit appuyer
sur ses poumons il pourra plus assurer
bientôt l'être y construit mon grand
sérail au début d'épisode c'est toi qui
me réveiller maintenant c'est moi qui
doit payer
on va vraiment faire les choses à tour
de rôle c'est ça qui est bon ou pas
c'est parce que si tous qu'ils soient de
l'autre côté de la grosse lumière encore
la mecque je peux pas l'aider quoi je
peux vraiment pas l'aider écoute je vais
sortir on va voir si on peut aller
chercher de l'aide
trucs improbables il arrivera jamais
dangereux on les deux et tout le monde
est contre nous oh [ __ ] il ya une
porte c'est ça sa sauvegarde et un
javelot je vais écouter ou consommer dès
qu'on pouvait prendre les javelots
m'avez menti
on m'avait menti on peut pas les prendre
l'idée était bonne mais on veut poste 1
oh what the fuck
je fais comment la à nikos a le vénère
si je laisse il a approché je crois
qu'il est en train de sortir
vous voilà il arrive
wahou badass tricot statut laissant
ainsi plein d'amour tu viens direct
toiture applique direct et bim
alors qu'on se perde ça fait moins le
cac et un hp l'ua au jamais fait ça ça
va on est bon on peut continuer notre
route et faire une chute
allez on va aller vers la bataille
follow me ouais ça c'est manière de
descendre mais pour toi mon gars c'est
que la rumba moi qui vais descendre
grâce à un [ __ ] ça sent là ça sent le
total wipeout deuxième édition
voilà épouser sa petite gueulante
allez on descend ça comtois gamin ok je
veux tu vends bien ouais là dessus ça à
se péter la gueule on va devoir trouver
un mort voilà
oh [ __ ]
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouvrir la veille
à des miroirs au bout il va se bloquer
pascal et miroirs au bout très bien donc
tu vas pas continuer ta les miroirs ils
sont moins là tu peux faire un effort
mais ça avance un petit peu c'est le
jour où tricot la plupart des miroirs ou
pas s'approche prénom et la turballe je
vais aller me voir séparables bon ça
c'est plus grave
du coup bon faut que je saute du coup en
face au juste en bas juste en bas je
suppose ouais remonter le hockey ça
chose ça va être un coup à base de
garder tricot pouvons pas nous aider où
ça
maintenant faut que j'arrête ou
l'arganier fait ok on est contre le mur
donc faut bien les la barre à contourner
auquel nous qu'on suspende on est très
bien pas suspendu ok on est en train de
contourner tout le bâtiment
j'aimerais pas qu'une star murat par ici
un suivi est ce que je vais dire ça me
ferait empoché il c'est quoi ce bâtiment
en direct qui contient quelque chose de
spécial il a vu la texture n'a jamais vu
un match avec une texture comme ça dans
mes souvenirs début il ya des espèces de
d'inscription contre le mur très bizarre
ce bâtiment je suis je suis persuadé
qu'il contient soit un truc spécial soit
un max de garde ou alors les deux quais
on monte maintenant je gagne en hauteur
en verticalité comme on dit à une grille
à regarder peut-être qu'un trop le truc
spécial c'est quoi ça et mes skis c'est
pas ça peut être le retour du miroir là
un fait contrer un truc et qu'on le foot
dedans ça
donc là je pense qu'on est remonté à
hauteur de tricot on va arriver de
l'autre côté on a poussé les les
vilaines vitre en forme d'oeil on est
pas tarder à voir tiko voilà il est là
bas il est fâché un [ __ ]
ah ya une porte mais qu'à gauche c'est
pas trés il ya deux portes là ça va
arriver c'est l'arrivée sur deux d'avoir
un détecteur un truc et je vais avoir
très peu de temps pour que télé miroir
ok le premier c'est bon oh merde
pourquoi pourquoi j'ai pris gravière de
loin comme ça laissez moi voilà il me
voit tellement de sortes
je peux rien faire je suis bloqué tu
peux rien faire je reçois trop de sorts
les gars je peux pas m'en sortir je peux
rien faire ils vont me choper soit c'est
un bug soit à temps mais c'est un chef
ça moi
envoyez un monde mais je pense
est-ce que tricot faut que tu bats ta
paire dames et loire sont foutus tricot
haut
ça y est
il a fait face sur sa peur mec
il ya volé
tu as volé mon grand je suis fier de toi
petit rico grandit tellement c'est
[ __ ]
j'arrive j'arrive plein sexuelle c'est
pas très stable c'est mon levier juste
ok au plat
c'est bon il s'en sort h peut pas bouger
c'est bon
[ __ ] enfin je redescende pour activer
le levier sera comment il me regarde
c'est horrible c'est pour ça que ça
c'était là depuis le début
j'arrive montgrand tient coup on a
bouffé
ah que là que là que là que la queue sur
la marchandise
j'arrive sur un soutien que j'arrive
désolé perd des plumes en plus ça se
précise tous les séparent décline donc
encore nécessaire on perd des cheveux ok
allez vas-y à la et cette fois c'est la
bonne
je suis lâché la main un briquet là
dessus
on est dans cette foire
[ __ ] mais c'est dingue assez bon
nickel et on viendrait à je vais sauter
dans la bouche tu me laisse pas tomber
nerfs c'est mon pote
abbott wilko
merci mon grand
parti sans qu'il y ait tout line of
patrick ou non à gagner était loving you
agathe ouguiyas ige thoune eysines à la
cool au foot ue au t1 alice nationale et
dé tous ces paravents d'aralar est donc
c'est bien nous étions si proches je
pense qu'il parle donc de la tour qui
étaient là bas et qui est très spécial
il y avait même vous avez cette espèce
de truc qu'on a vu devant la porte on
sait toujours pas ce que c'est quoi bon
bah écoute tricot un la vie continue on
reprend notre route
c'est quoi tu marche à reculons mais
qu'est ce tu fous autant alors on
atterri ici bas et tricot je vais je
vais avoir besoin de toi
nice on n'a pas grand chose à faire et
c'est un très bien sur le toi tu peux
tenir soit ou pas
j'ai pas c'était une bonne idée
rappelle toi ici ok très bien
[ __ ] c'est terrible c'est frustrant
parce qu'on fait que de gagner en
hauteur et de perdre en hauteur et de
gagner en hauteur et de perdre en
hauteur abbassi si je pense je pense à
retrouve au fond des centres tricot faut
descendre jusque là en bas tu vois tu es
assis là ou ailleurs pour toi juste là
où j'avais pas vu yep
merci chico on est bien là alors on va y
aller ok donc nouveau bâtiment avec une
armure avec des armures [ __ ] d'entrée
de jeu kouassi s'échauffent moi même mec
je tenir en lambeaux je pars pas de
voiture je l'excellent hockey sasuke et
ben vas-y 1 2 c'est ce qui te reste à
faire
il s'est carrément tout fait en 2 2 donc
je vais je vais davance péter le truc et
à la batterie et aux saloperies mieux
salo what the fuck c'est particulier il
ya deux chaînes derrière qu'est ce que
c'est que ça houla non si c'est bon ok
je poussais
or on va trouver miroir regarder
il ya ces espèces de portes à casser
avec le miroir comme au début du jeu à
moins que bon à mon avis ces chaînes ne
sont pas là pour rien quoi qu'elle mène
nulle part
donc je pense qu'elle est petite escale
est derrière à gauche qu'on va devoir
trancher voyez quelque part allons-y à
bail un levier jusque là tu as parfait
qu'est ce que ça fait ça va lever le
pont le pc et ben voilà
parfait on apprécie sa [ __ ]
[ __ ] ça être la fac up
depuis les armures etc
[Musique]
je refais levier il ya que le méchant
qui sont la partie du pont qui se
baissent
clairement ces matières dégager ce qu'on
lâche tricorps
rapidement ils achètent
comment je fais moi je me laisse tomber
ouais je pense que ça
tomber surtout qu il a dit
désolé ticos cause des combats la
barrière qui a fait rien levier c'est
parti
mais moi toute fin
[ __ ] ça
ok ok j'ai immédiatement compris ce
qu'il faut faire comprendre là que deux
seront pas tard et la mairie si oui
comment je peux faire à oak et de
l'autre côté il ya la même porte j'ai
compris [ __ ] et ces laissez moi passer
les mois passent et maintenant on va
passer vous m'avez gonflé mois passé
s'il vous plaît elle à les deux titans
qui se passe j'aimerais passer et on n'a
pas tout notre temps on dépêche toi
ok c'est là je vais prendre ça que et je
te jure qu'il va regretter d'avoir une
que mon pote il va regretter mais
vraiment attention dans ta que tu vas
morfler mon pote
cliquez sur ma maman
c'est partout brick lane
quand merde cause par le bel en bas et
qui soudain faire mal an
un peu limitera ok je me suis rattrapé
ya une chaîne du bouquet de chaînes qui
pendait voilà il me l'avait bien en
évidence elle mais nous au gardien je
suppose non c'est quoi ça un truc à
pousser qui va tomber sur l'autocar je
les avais je suis en total total stress
c'est un truc de malade
ok je laisse à bille
[ __ ] elle est super longue en plus
avec votre compte on y est tricot tient
le coup mon corps tient le coup tient le
coup je vais très j'ose même pas regardé
j'ai pas envie de voir inquiéter je vais
te donner d'abord après c'est promis ces
projets c'est promis c'est promis c'est
une sale journée pour toi ça arrive on
en connaît tous c'est comme ça comment
je fais là quand je pousse ça c'est
super et c'est bon
un petit peu là ça tombe bien en dessus
sia merde ça finit
alors là explosé quoi temps d'accès qui
m'a surpris
retire ça y est on est assez
[Musique]
ok tu es qu est ce que t co va bien est
ce que tricot va bien ah merde au maire
de nanterre est un visage est ma devise
est tu vas tomber fait pas savoir du
vide gamin tricot savoir comment ça va
faire un petit signe de vie ça va ça va
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais
c'est le miroir mec tu avait avalé
miroir mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
tricot c'est des manières ça va aller
non je sais que ça sera pas que tu fais
ton pouvoir tétreault claqué mais je
vais t'emmener très vite à bouffer t'en
fais pas dans le prochaine épisode les
amis j'espère que si c'est le cas
c'était génial ce combat enfin enfin ils
se battent kouao on n'arrêtait pas de le
croiser n'y avait jamais tricot qui
étaient là on a été tout le temps
séparés et là enfin on a fait une vraie
baston problème c'est qu'il a l'air plus
entraînés en plus ils et d'armures
donkey le fdp et moi je vous dis à très
vite pour approcher un épisode portez
vous bien tu as tout le monde dise
[Musique]